[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and here we are again listeners it's
episode 46 46 they're flying by they are
yes it will be 50 we'll have to do
something exciting for 50 years episode
I don't know what the hell we're going
to do maybe we got a bunch oh it's about
Mars yes
this this topic was inspired by what you
actually saw I've been you yes I'm
picture that was going around yeah
that's right interesting I think that's
happening on Mars right now
one you got alien space junk sitting on
the surface of Mars
alright - you got child slave camps on
Mars
we're going to talk about that so that
gave us the idea - but I said you know
well actually it was your ideas like
well let's do a show about all the crazy
[ __ ] about Mars yeah but also kind of
about some of the scientific stuff -
like real scientific yeah about how
likely it is on Mars and why people
first started thinking there and they
separate the wheat from the chaff and
some of these some of these conspiracy
theories are pretty they're funny crazy
yeah funny but crazy yes and we're going
to get to the space junk and we're also
going to get to the child slave camps
help I already got down to the bottom of
it yeah like like you even need to yeah
it's like a minute somebody says child
slaves on Mars I'm just like no well you
know I was watching out Alex Jones live
on a live stream when the guy mentions
the slave camps on Mars and I was like
but I quickly found out what was talking
about it what we'll get to it we'll get
to it later on yeah all right so like we
do at the beginning before we get to the
topic I'm gonna do a couple of shout
outs first thing on a shadow - project
Entertainment Network sometimes I forget
are you guys doing really good we've our
numbers are really good he's been doing
a great job there's a lot of really cool
other podcasts on there also some of the
people from Project Entertainment
Network including our mod Rose Amelia
are going to be at scares that care in
Williamsburg Virginia July 21st through
23rd convention there so if you want to
go and meet them or see them they also
have a patreon page set up they're
selling
t-shirts for a bunch of the podcasts and
they're really cool so you might want to
look into that scarcity air and it's the
end of this month and also I usually
give a shout out to my book the unseen
hand which has been selling really well
and I thank everybody that bought it and
reviewed it and everything like that we
had a huge show on where the roads go
yes that may turn out to be a three
parter it's definitely be a two-part
yeah yeah I just I recorded an interview
with Sariah from where did the road go
and he just put it up to part one and he
wants to do a part two also because
there was just I mean the unseen hand
there's so much stuff in there which you
know like I said I didn't really intend
at first but it ended up being like
twice as long a book as I was planning
yes so you know there's a lot of ground
to cover
yes sir I love this book he loves
poltergeist phenomenon and you know we
talked to him offline you know a lot of
times I mean he's really interested in
art in art a poltergeist and also you
know what mountain AMA and everything so
you know he thinks this is a benchmark
book so so do I actually there has there
hasn't been a book written like this in
a long time yeah I mean and that's kind
of what I wanted to deal with I kind of
wanted to bring back the old-school
poltergeist sides and draw a thing so
yeah go check out the latest episode of
where did the road go and then part one
and then we're going to do part two at
some point in the near future and the
only other thing I wanted to mention and
I've mentioned this before end of
October October 27th through 29th is
spooky Empire in Orlando Florida and we
will both be there run up some panels
run in some panels we all know look we
will have a table we will be there all
three days so you can come see us you
know sitting on some of the panels and
talking about I may or may not have
booze for you yeah maybe we might we
probably will as long as we run out yeah
we're gonna have to take a lot because
we know we know well last yeah last time
we had all those little little sample
bottles we were handed out boom yeah
yeah
oh I thought about that Jim Beam at
green-apple was pretty good I know yeah
even though our bartender does not like
it said it's too sweet it's good though
he doesn't like anything I like he's
even like even like force awakens
hahahahaha brewery
yeah he just likes to be
terney because you know he likes you to
pretend he's cooler let's get to the
show all right so that's all the show
notes we have today so let's get to Mars
they're going to talk about Mars
now Mars first seen through a telescope
in the 17th century yeah because it's
kind of similar to Earth I mean not so
much you know it's only about half the
size but it has you know a similar you
know rotation today is about the same
length
it has axial tilt so it has seasons that
are kind of like ours even though the
year is much longer so it's not really
that surprising that people before
before the 20th century believe that
there might be life on there it's not a
dumb idea right you know what I mean
because they didn't know they couldn't
see it very clearly and you know later
on when they first could see it sort of
better through a telescope and it looks
like there were quote-unquote
kinetic and now on it now what happened
with that was that the first person to
to see those was Giovanni shepper le I
don't think that he proposed that they
were man-made and another thing he
didn't call them canal that's a
mistranslation from the Italian Canali
it's canal II which actually means
channels right is all that man right
ridges yeah so he mapped them but I
don't believe in his in any of his
writing T I've ever said that he thought
they were man-made it was just later on
when Percival Lowell got hold of it he's
like canal that must be like the Erie
Canal like people built it they kind of
you know yeah it was kind of a thing
where they thought that there were
people yeah the telescope's at the time
really didn't have the resolution you
really couldn't see clearly and they did
dump tests over and over again it's an
optical illusion you could not see any
canals or any kind of patterns in them
yeah there's no uniformity in the
drawings what it was is there was a
light there's like a light spot and a
couple of dark parts on it and if you
stare at it long enough your mind can
play tricks on you because each artist
had his own kind of take on what it was
he was seeing you could see that his
drawings would have a certain theme
of how big the channels were which
direction they ran they weren't
consistent they were only consistent for
each man you know what yeah each each
guy had his own vision of what what he
was seeing
but really later on you know it's proved
when the telescope's got a lot better
but they weren't seeing any of that no
Aaron is all tricky and honestly when
they got to the you know survey it was
spectrographs and things like that you
know they could see that it wasn't
canals but you know by that time the
canals on Mars idea had gotten so like
seep so much into the public
consciousness
you know HG Wells or the Worlds and you
know even up through pretty much the
1950s and 60s there were a lot of like
you know be horror sci-fi movies you
know women you know Mars Needs women and
you know there are stacks and things
like that where there could be people on
there's a huge misconception that the
idea of extraterrestrials or alien life
is somehow new and that if people were
to find out that there were
extraterrestrials that civilization
would collapse it's all bull and in in
the 1800s the average person believed
that people lived on Mars they were
drawing it yeah they had crazy drawings
of aliens with parasols running around
kind of like a weird version of France
that's so preferred yeah it kind of look
like all right what's the difference
yeah you know France on Mars that most
most people believe in extraterrestrials
that always kind of cracked me up though
it's like how how provincial how
parochial is that to think that here's
like another planet there's millions and
millions of miles away and the people on
it look exactly like people on earth
they dress like people on earth they do
the same [ __ ] as people on earth
well Ron it sounds very very funny so
some of them didn't they were kind of
humanoid sir yeah ours was wrong kind of
humanoid but with weird round eyes and
like suction cups for miles but they're
dressed up that parasol but you know
they smoke yeah kind of funny units you
know why wouldn't you miss it so okay so
like I said all through the fifties so
people still kind of thought well it's
possible that there could be humanoids
or you know another type of humans
living on Mars and it wasn't really
until probably
the 1960s when they first had this the
Mariner space probe flyby they're taking
pictures of it and the pictures were
kind of shitty I mean you know in 1965
they were black and white at that point
they took pictures of the surface and
there was like nothing there was just
like rocks and dust it looks like
generators and [ __ ] it looks like the
Mojave Desert everywhere yeah but one
thing though is that you look at you if
you look at photos or you know to me
some of photography that they have now
on the surface of Mars is awesome yeah
it looks like you're sent here you're
sitting there in the middle of Arizona
or something it really does be okay but
it's not that atmosphere SID it's like
only a little bit thicker than the moon
well there's only 1% of our yeah and see
the thing is and that's not to say that
there wasn't life on her on Mars at some
point because at some point Mars did
have an atmosphere yeah a long time ago
and it did have water yeah but see the
thing is what they what they think
happened the going theory right now the
most likely theory is that at some point
in the past Mars was hit by a huge
asteroid or something like that and the
asteroid was so large that it disrupted
Mars's orbit or its wobble or whatever
and the molten core inside because it
did once have a molten core because
they're dead volcanoes on it kind of got
messed up and that messed up the
planet's magnetic field okay and since
its magnetic field was disrupted then
that was no longer protected from solar
winds the filter window or theory pretty
much yet or when it blew the atmosphere
off okay because I wasn't even sure it
had enough mask to maintain an
atmosphere for long I stopped it but
things like I said they think it did
used to have them it doesn't have me
because it did have a lot of liquid
water at some point because there are
riverbeds there are all kind of stuff
there you know and there's still a
little bit wrong now but it's like
underneath the surface and it's it
doesn't have a big iron core like a
repeater I mean it doesn't it doesn't
have any plate tectonics or no I don't
think there's any volcanic activity not
anymore not any man has one of the
largest volcanoes in
Moeller system it's the third yes was it
Olympus Olympus Mons yeah but I don't
think that's been active since the
dinosaur age yeah for yeah so I don't
think there could have been an
atmosphere on it by memory I just
remember them saying that it lost its
atmosphere before the earth was even
habitable
yeah that's not about right oh yeah I
think that's right I'm not to check but
I didn't so much the dinosaur ages know
if yeah it was a very long long time
very long right the earth was not
earth-like there in the time when Mars
may have had an atmosphere yes
which kind of brings me to another thing
and this is sometimes listed as a
conspiracy theory but I don't think I
would call it that I would call it just
a regular theory because it's actually
kind of plausible is that Mars orbit
Earth's the early Earth was seeded by
life forms no Mars panspermia plant
panspermia now this idea kind of came
you know it's been around for a long
time but it became more likely in the
80s when they found a meteorite up in
Antarctica that they knew was from Mars
because its chemical composition was
exactly the same as the Martian surface
and when they opened it up it looked
like there were all these little bottles
in there that kind of look like worms
are like microbes yeah now they're still
arguing now some scientists say it is
microbes I'm sad to say it's not
microbes but it could be and it could be
that Mars was hit at some point in the
past little chunks of the planet flew
off that had little microbes in them
fell onto the earth and that kind of
kickstart a life on this planet an asset
I've scientist is never going to tell
you that there's life on Mars until they
absolutely yeah no that's what I mean
that's what science is you have to be
absolutely sure right but that's what
that evidently evidence is some of the
scientists believe that yeah it probably
was and from what I saw it was about
half and half it's like I'm more like
yeah I think it is I mean they're not
going to say yes it is they're going to
say I saw some photos that came from one
of the early
overs yeah what was that very first
Rover well spirit an opportunity went up
about the same about the same time and I
think it came from me the spirit or
opportunity or some photographs of
things that were on the market Marshal
Service
they look awful lot like a primitive
coral yeah I've seen that thing yeah
yeah I would probably you know it's just
off the top of my head just surmising if
there were ever life on on Mars probably
didn't exist for very long and probably
couldn't have gotten much past the level
of primitive sea life so call barnacles
maybe something like that yeah but I
wouldn't even say fish fish is pretty
advanced yeah and it took a long time
long time forget it a fish on earth
right so I'm thinking invertebrates you
know things like coral things like maybe
sea anenome yeah that might be your rule
yes Sumerians are kind of a prime more
like things like call them in
microscopic organisms yeah teria things
like that which you know that's cool
enough to fill up you think that's
something like that you know evolved on
Mars like you said I don't think it got
if if that did indeed happen I don't
think it got any more advanced than that
before not everything went to [ __ ] right
it could have gotten they probably could
have advanced along normal lives and
bent earth like had that environment
been habitable long enough yeah I don't
think it had was what was based on
everything scientific I've seen it
wasn't habitable long enough yeah
before this Cataclysm I admit war had
lost its whereas the atmosphere without
some means right and you know like I
said they think that that's why I
brought the magnetic fields was just
robbed now could there be something
alive on it now yeah there'd be little
microbes like with it what that little
cyanobacteria type stuff yeah that'd
soil there's some evidence that you know
water comes out of the surface every now
and then but what's weird is that a
liquid water boils away I think at that
pressure pretty quickly
yeah asked a freeze in order for it to
be there to very well I think that's how
they actually knew because remember they
had the I believe it was the Phoenix
lander that went up and landed on the
pole
and they now see some of the ice on
there is made of carbon dioxide wretches
not well so it can sit but when they dug
down they saw something white down there
and they said oh we hope that this is
water I have to not carbon dioxide a so
what they did was they dug this the
trench out and then they left it exposed
yes they said no this is water ice it
will vaporize right and it did do the
restaurant so there what there is water
ice on there and like I said they know
that there was water on there at some
point
is there still water under the surface
probably could be ground is there
something alive that it could be well
you know here you have underground caves
with water enema yeah you might have a
situation like that there I know there's
no proof of that but maybe yeah it could
be it wouldn't it wouldn't shock and if
life came about long ago on Mars maybe
it has survived so in underground
yeah but I'm guarantee is just bacteria
bro yeah I'm sure that's all it is I
mean you're a big enough ecosystem yeah
like an underground fish to a boil but
it would never do like your kind of
extreme of file size and you have to is
here on earth that live like in you know
as poisonous events and things like that
it would be saying something like that
so you want to get some of these crazy
conspiracy theories or crazy ideas about
Mars that we could yeah now talk about
the one that you saw the picture of and
the guy that was talking about the child
slaves because this is a good one this
is like the most recent one oh yeah the
dumbest the dumbest one by far that is
pretty dumb on how it's Jones I do watch
out Jones Alex Jones I think you know
he's entertaining you know it's it's not
news per se it's a show and he's going
to talk about the news that you got a
chit you got to watch Alex because Alex
can put some spin on things
well he had a guest on that mentioned
Martian child sex slaves or child sex
slaves being held on Mars and that was
too much even for Alex Jones AJ is like
oh wait hold on now Donna you know if
the media will jump on me for things
like that and I was like what the hell's
he talking about and the closest thing I
could come up with is that there were
NASA scientists throughout the you know
over the years have come up with an idea
that well maybe we can breathe
children okay in space capsule type
environments and in an enclosed
environment to be used on missions like
Mars missions and space missions in the
future and for them they wouldn't find
that to be a horror environments no any
different because they grew up in that
yeah and that was just somebody had some
guys mentioned yeah some guy blue sky
you know maybe so today when we're going
to colonize Mars maybe we can start
doing this so people won't be you know
so this guest kind of conflated greeting
children in captivity with child slavery
so they're therefore it must be sex
slavery on Mars which it was a lot about
that guy
so that is that says a lot about my
lookout but that's what he was talking
about that's what that's what I believe
he was talking about me he I believe is
he just sexed it up a little bit yeah
what I missed understandably heard it
only you know briefly or somebody else
told him that and he ran it with filter
did yelled her through through the
[ __ ] of the [ __ ] the do [ __ ]
layer to [ __ ] layer that through a
couple of different people have repeated
it you know and then you can see like on
what by the NASA is taking child sex
slaves to Mars there's a lot of that
[ __ ] it does a lot of that [ __ ] online
you're a crazy person another one it's
online right now is the space junk
sitting on the Martian surface
yeah well we investigated that tell us
about this thing well the photo the only
photos the only isn't the only source I
hesitate to use that the only source of
this photo that I could find was it was
from a reddit thread basically so did it
really come from NASA who knows like I
said I can Photoshop a picture that
looks like some shifts at non Mars and
put a little copyright NASA in a corner
it's not it didn't come from a an
official NASA NASA not that I know of
I'm just lying make you fine as far as I
can find it turn up on a reddit thread
so somebody could have made it it could
be from NASA
but even if it is from NASA and you out
of context yeah it might be in a contest
is it anything if it's something like it
kind of looks like what is it kind of
like is my guitar Calibri like a metal
like a plate plate yet or a bowl or
something Kyle looks like you cut a
circular section out of the wall of an
aircraft and threw it on the ground yeah
that's what it looks like to me which
look even if it's a real picture I'll
guarantee you that is okay because a lot
of [ __ ] has been set in orbit around
bars there been Rovers said to Mars not
just us you know they have other you
know the Europeans Asians and Russians
have done it so much better idea so it's
like even if it is a metal thing sitting
there this means that aliens down it
wouldn't be alien probably some crap we
left there yeah before it fell on the
surface or something it'd be some earth
space junk yeah and there's a lot of
that already sitting there on the
surface of Mars
yeah Landers and things like that pieces
of landing craft and you know like you
had that damn machine that went down to
put the rover on the surface that we
have now yeah well weird that we're in a
couple of them I can tell you vehicles
laying yeah well I think a couple of the
couple of the ones that they sent before
Phoenix which is the one that was at the
pole the ones they said before that
failed when they lost them and I think
they've tried to put satellites into
orbit that failed right and I don't know
what Adam
I think satellite re-entry into into
Mars wouldn't be as violent to satellite
re-entry to earth yeah Holly wouldn't
burn up yeah we just hit seem I just get
little pieces as well pieces oh it
everywhere so you know I I don't think
there's anything mysterious about that
not even if you did find a real picture
of something that looked like a metal
doohickey like sitting on its cool
picture probably not real yeah I think
it's probably into it and let's talk
about this a little bit because this is
probably the most famous like conspiracy
theory about Mars that people think
about its Richard Hoagland and yes face
on Mars pyramids on Mars cities on Mars
he just has a whole Richard holdman is
the granddaddy of Mars stories yeah and
I actually like Richard holdman
I could sit there and listen to him tell
me about Cydonia and everything and as
long as you don't see photographs of
what it is he talking about you can kind
of buy into it you know you can kind of
imagine yeah maybe there would was
something that a long time ago a
civilization and you know
but when you see what it is he's talking
about now
no it's rocks yeah rock will see every
time like every time I go to the dumbass
conspiracy theory studies and they're
like look at this pictures of something
on Mars and I'm like yeah it's a rock
and that's also a rock and there's
another rock there's like they don't
look like anything that is a human mind
has a very good ability to make patterns
well that's what your brain is for right
you're supposed to make patterns you're
supposed to make connections you know
that's that's what the brain evolved to
do right but the problem is that you a
lot of times that makes you see things
that aren't really there yeah
okay now the face on Mars obviously that
iconic picture of the face on Mars you
know that everybody fakes up that's the
only picture that looked like a face the
rest of it just looks like of Mountain
Ridge yeah when they took other pictures
like every other picture of that area it
doesn't look like [ __ ] it just looks
like a little Ridge or a little mountain
or something like that this was very
funny when I looked this up because you
think that that would be definitive
here's pictures we took a bunch of more
pictures of the quote-unquote face on
Mars and it doesn't look like anything
it doesn't look like a face it was just
a trick of the light that's all it was
okay but some conspiracy theorists I
love this they said no there was a face
on Mars there that because that picture
was from the Viking mission in 1976 I
believe that picture came from there was
a face there but NASA was trying to
cover it up so when they sent the Spirit
and Opportunity Rovers the rover's had
explosives on there and they blew it up
right which that leads me that leads me
to another aspect of the whole one style
kind of stories about cities on Mars
they always say that NASA is preventing
us from knowing about this that they
know about it and they don't want the
public to know [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] that would be like going to Las
Vegas and getting the largest jackpot in
the Las Vegas history and then failing
to go to the collection window to
collect on it yes that's exactly what
because that's what NASA would be
looking for if they found an alien
structure on Mars they beat
it'd be like look we found an alien
structure a structure on Mars we have to
be there next year give us all the money
yeah give us all the money we were going
to always point the whole point of them
spending trillions and billions of
dollars going there that's why I want to
see if there was life there there's
nothing for water they're looking for
things and if they found it if they
found an alien structure on Mars they
would be just be given so much money
their budget they would be partying down
right exactly partying down yeah all
right they could write their own ticket
I mean did you see how excited they got
like I was watching a documentary did
you see how excited they got when they
found out that with liquid water yeah
they were hugging and high-fiving it was
my own room and says like that if they
actually found like something that was
indicative of an alien civilization I'm
art they would be wetting themselves
with joy you almost said alien
civilization the family of syphilis
syphilis see you come back to that
effects plaything yeah it lets me know
if they were to find an alien structure
on anything here in the solar system it
would be a priority
yeah over there one yeah it would make
so much Bank my letters these would be
get so much money
that it wouldn't be fine so yeah another
dumb thing to is that and this is a disk
is kind of like about I have this
problem with a lot of conspiracy
theories if NASA really wanted to cover
this [ __ ] up why release the pictures
yeah
why put the pictures out you never see
them you'd never see and they were just
fit to leave let's talk about oh you
know what is it time it's almost time to
uh oh okay yeah so let's say well I look
at the time and I'm just like oh [ __ ]
time's going by I told you I told you
this to be a fun show yeah okay alright
my idea yeah yeah yeah good idea in the
Digga Rigga office yeah
yes Rosita that's his Darth Vader moment
okay so we're going to take a break
right now when we back in just a minute
with more crazy Mars conspiracy theory
squiddy's Reyes
do you pop do you 25
do you bleed D sickness since critters
risk is your case do some time with a
crew of authors artists did others of
area time we have a case of using the
bridge energy of magic missiles over to
do dog is sliders in your ear hole would
let us work our magic Villa vibes every
Thursday on the project indicating it
way then I'll have your attention for
the morning announcement please be
advised salons ratings book club is
coming to project Entertainment Network
going felling memory and actually that
they just have to be pleased you over
booked horror thriller whatever they
want to leave and reveal a blonde a
brunette and a redhead welcome to a book
store and they're serving up hot book
reviews so unrelated to this book club
coming soon
exclusively on project entertainment
network would you now stand for the
national anthem don't get your lunch
money stolen subculture corsets in
clothing is our favorite store for
unusual clothing shoes and accessories
they offer a wide selection of men's and
women's clothing at great prices so
culture also offers the cool selection
of shoes and accessories steampunk
gothic apparel retro corsets and so much
more at subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets comm set subculture
corsets calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 hi this is Brian
Keene I'm an international best-selling
award-winning are novelty no I know
where the bodies are buried and now I'm
telling you they're located every week
on the horror show
Marga no comment understand we discussed
the latest news of our novels movies
comics and games and interview the
biggest names in the business
this is no comment
Thursday night 7:00 p.m. only projects
Entertainment Network
[Music]
[Music]
so we were talking about face on Mars
pyramids on Mars and stuff like that and
I said this is another problem I have a
lot of conspiracy theories too is that
here's one too late about the whole like
Stanley Kubrick helped fake the moon
landing and yeah we put Clouseau to the
shining it's like look if no one if they
didn't want you to find [ __ ] out they
wouldn't have any clues they wouldn't
leave clues for anybody they wouldn't
let pictures get out they would just say
wooden and if they were gonna fake the
moon landing they never would have built
on those saturn v rockets
wait we live to the moon many times well
oh yeah yeah and speaking it right
easier to go to vote go to the moon they
do fake going to the moon by building on
wasting your head with rocks you must go
I would you do that and yeah we have the
plans to the Saturn five rockets and the
plans to build a life stuff and guess
what all the science checks out that's
how you get to the moon yeah i building
that Occam's razor yo that it's like
don't make stuff more complicated than
it is okay it's like now that in that
you mentioned like the whole moon
landing conspiracy theory there are also
Mars that we didn't land there
conspiracy theories about that because
here's the dumping here we're getting
like the conspiracy theorists are kind
of battling against each other because
you have the one faction of conspiracy
theorists that's saying there's all this
a there's all these alien life-forms on
Mars there's a snake there's a skull
there's bones there's a rat I think our
gerbil or whatever it was I want Stan
there there's a woman saying that
there's a Bigfoot on there or they're
not melted they're not calling a big
fellow so damn it looks like a Bigfoot
on Mars the new sci-fi movie I'm
surprised they haven't made what they
probably already made one anyway and
then there's another faction that saying
well yeah all those photos are real but
these photos don't prove that there's
alien life on Mars they prove that NASA
never went to Mars and they're taking
these pictures on earth okay and they're
getting place courses so they're getting
like oh yeah they're that they're taking
them on Devon island which actually NASA
does have training missions yeah where
they do like turning it or you know into
simulations there we go that's the word
I was looking for where they do
simulations because it's similar to the
terrain or whatever so some people are
saying that we never went to Mars
all these pictures that are coming from
Mars no actually from a I was a little
kid watch the Viking Mars Lander turn on
live on television yeah it worked formed
that picture yeah yeah I watched that
happen laughs it took forever for that
picture to come through yeah all right
let's get to the 10 craziest stories
about yeah now so well a couple of these
we already mentioned like the pyramids
like we really and stuff like that now
actually this I had never heard this
conspiracy theory but this is already my
favorite no I don't know why I just
think this one's adorable so some people
think that Phobos Mars's moon is not a
moon but a space station a station to
obi-wan Kenobi that's no moon it's a
space station there we go
just a Death Star yeah it does come even
though let's kind of like a little
potato like the floating around is the
best honor potato head a baby yeah okay
but the reason that some whack-job
started thinking that is because the
European Space Agency and also the
Russian the Russian space agency have
said that Phobos appears to be Hollow
but they're not talking about hollow
like a cheap Easter chocolate bunny
Hollow they're saying it looks like
either there could be maybe water in
there or it was formed by a bunch of
asteroids like kind of smacking together
so there's like holes in there right I
made like a little air pocket they're
not saying it's like hollow like a right
you know like Pinterest Darth Vader and
the rock surfers walk it or not it's not
big first let's understand focus isn't
very big no it's that Oh what is it the
3730 miles cross yeah like it's just
like a little tiny rock you're watching
you you could walk around it in less
than a day yeah that's a little so
amazing station in space space stuff
especially if it's something from the
asteroid belts you know it's all your
regular yeah just rocks yeah jump rocks
now bolstering the conspiracy theories
claims so they say is that every time we
have tried to send
oops to Phobos there's always been some
kind of system failure
yeah so they're saying that you know
absolute little Darth Vader's and
they're going PPP you and IT low-quality
probes it's like shooting down the
probes no you can't find out that this
is like a little potato chip duster
leave us alone so you could you bump
that easily there's never any artificial
lighting on it if it was the Death Star
would have lights well you think they
can't be walking around in the dark in
there unless they're all like cat people
should they can see in the dark
probably captured space junk yeah
something on it from the asteroid though
that's probably all it is but yeah it's
definitely not but for some reason
that's I just thought that was a cutest
random rocks everywhere yeah it's just
random rock random rocks everywhere and
now we already talked about this is
mainly Richard Hoagland saying that the
whole area where the face on Mars is
that there's also pyramids there Cydonia
yes I don't answer them and also it's
Sphinx which I've never seen a picture
of that and the pyramids like I said
every time they show the quote-unquote
pyramids they say they're supposed to be
three about my favorite I'm like yeah
Mountains it looks like a mountain yeah
well you know I got to give Hoagland do
you know a little bit of credit there
interesting terrain features I will send
a lander over there to go look at it
yeah just see what it looked like you
would it all look like but I'm guarantee
you if you're so when I was in the army
you could look at a map a topographical
map a military map and you can see what
it looks really interesting on the map
but when you get there it looks like
everywhere else if you were to send a
lander to that area it would just look
like the rest of Mars boring yeah and
you'd have to drive a long way or take
the tip of the lander long way to get to
a terrain feature and when you got there
would just be kinda like a random Hill
then you drive somewhere else in another
direction to find another random hill
because you're not seeing all that at
once if you're looking down on it yeah
now you know you've seen it at a much
smaller scale you can kind of form a
pattern out of it with your mom oh and
it looks really cool but it doesn't look
like that from the surface no of course
not I mean look at all the crazy I mean
there are whole entire websites that
catalogue look at this crazy [ __ ] on
Google Earth right you know that looks
like a something it looks like a skull
it looks like there's nothing there like
when you go look at it on the surface
there it just looks like that from from
a distance yeah yeah from a distance it
looks it looks like that same thing is
when you look up in the clouds and you
see black people's faces and [ __ ] like
that it doesn't look like anything and
like I said the pyramids quote-unquote
do not look like pyramids to me no yeah
they look like a pyramids from a
distance innately like a pyramid yes but
if you were to be there on purpose here
look like a hermit but if you if you
were to be there on the surface it
wouldn't look like anything unusual it
look like the rest of the hills and
mountains and all Mars yeah it just
looks the same too and you know like I
said this is kind of the same thing that
happens with a lot of things is that
rocks can take a lot of a lot of strange
shapes which they do on earth also yeah
and anything that looks like just
randomly that looks like a sort of like
a thing I mean you're gonna think it's
that thing but yeah it looks like a
thing it's a thing looks good yeah you
know what I'm saying again he's like
always beep I was making fun of it he's
always making fun of me okay let's go
all the time wait I got one now this is
another one I had never heard of there
is a conspiracy theory that there was
actually a manned mission to Mars and it
was kept a secret called Project red Sun
okay right and who did this now this was
suppose this supposedly happened in the
1970s okay and that they were going and
that they were setting up a base on Mars
all right
apparently NASA started sending manned
space ships up there after the Apollo 17
mission and apparently this was it was
supposed to be a joint us-soviet
apparently according to WHO the people
who were just who were giving us this
according to crazy people okay
according to crazy well we don't know if
it's crazy according to people that
believe in this theory and apparently
there was more than one mission like the
first one and it's supposed to be joint
us-soviet is there okay it kind of makes
sense in a way is there any physical
evidence for this no okay okay continue
supposedly the first mission took place
in 1971 and that was supposed to be
introduced to gather information and
then there was supposed to be another
one there was another one in 1973 and
that there were two US astronauts and
one Russian cosmonaut
now the whole how this all came about
was in 2011 the video appeared on
YouTube because you know how YouTube is
like a really legitimate source of good
information that is supposed to be a
NASA training video about Project red
Sun most people see this video and said
it looks like it's made of Windows Movie
Maker yeah somebody made this you know
it's kind of like the alien autopsy type
of thing where's like you know it's a
decent looking folks but it looks like I
have to see it myself now yeah and keep
in mind to you today is that is that is
that a snap screenshot of it no this is
a different thing and keep in mind too
that the story is kind of gained ground
because in like the UFO circles
supposedly one of the astronauts was one
of the whistleblowers yeah I totally
went to Mardin oh yeah yeah I was like
I'll take them out yes now part of it
part of it had me thinking that it was
plausible that it happened in the 70s
they had back when NASA did have balls
but that's it couldn't keep any secrets
in the 1970s now the only they can know
is the only organization that could ever
go to Mars and keep it secret forever
would have been the CIA
yeah the skunkworks something like that
yeah levena is CIA on duty I am on Mars
whatever he is linked up with you know a
Grumman aerospace or something if the
I'm not even sure Grumman still exists
but yeah I don't know and that would
have only been never have only taken
place in the negative 70s maybe the 80s
but the thing is is that no again did
the journey too far yeah well yeah I
mean even with our current yeah you know
with our current technology it still
takes like eight months together right
something like that
so I think the shortest they can get it
down there's about six months yeah it
yeah it depends on where we are where
ours is because there's only like a
pretty short window where we can arrive
and I really want to do this with it
with a different propulsion system that
can even cut that down down down to
nearly nothing the only thing that we
really had a chance to get there
he asked me with old tech with the Orion
spaceship which is a nuclear-powered
putt-putt rocket yeah
and it was the size and weight the size
of the small building and you know
heavier than a submarine and it was
controlled nuclear external combustion
and it would have worked that was not
something crazy and it could have gone
to Mars in a few weeks that's how fast
it was and come back but what was it in
candy strapped it yeah we got a whole
show on the Orion spaceship you all
right that might be fun they wanted to
build like seven of them and the Air
Force wanted some and the army wanted
some and you think we're basically they
wanted to use it as nuclear platforms to
throw atomic bombs on on Russia
yeah and Kennedy was like oh man they're
making Death Star's now I don't want the
Russians would the Russians would
retaliate the Russians would not react
well no I don't think they would because
that's what they were that's we probably
right that's what the Air Force in the
US Army would have done is that they're
just what it kept them in constant Earth
orbit ready to drop atomic bomb really
like you said a Death Star a Death Star
that's essentially what they wanted they
were awful awful cool I saw well that
sir is cool I wouldn't wanted why like a
desk are those hanging out by my plan I
didn't look like a Death Star though it
looked like a submarine with a cold head
look like a submarine with a big dish on
the back of it with shock absorbers and
you threw atomic bombs out of the back
of it using it using an engine that was
basically like a coca-cola bottling
machine yes it could throw out three
little miniature atomic bombs second
each one of them the size of Campbell's
soup can and then just like a Coke
vending machine they would get stuck in
there and then you have to put another
head back up they had backup feed tracks
they had this thing worked out was a
totally mechanical engine it was often
go to work and the heavier the better
and it's totally contrary to a
spacecraft they want spacecraft now to
do really lightweight because you have a
lot of energy well it had to be as heavy
as possible to keep this thing from
tearing itself apart under all that
buffeting well atomic explosions behind
it which made making it very easy and
you could launch it from Earth but it
would be you'd be setting off a lot of
atomic bombs to get into orbit or that
was it why does everybody have cancer
around us launching they were going to
launch it out the middle of the ocean on
the launching platform
yeah
with basically a big flat tugboat it's
awesome wish they would have done maybe
someday like so how to fallout yeah okay
we gotta keep going
alright so this next one is kind of a
similar type of thing now this lady in
2014 she called him coast to coast again
real legitimate sorcerer coast to coast
fun program but yeah you gonna need some
most callers are quite well quick all
right art Belle George Noory all the
people that have like hosted it and
stuff like that respect that respect
yeah how can you like sit there and
lifted it because some of the people
that call like some people call are not
too crazy and like they have like it
really is there's some good guests and
stuff but it's like every now and
especially they have open lines I can't
even listen to the open lawn show laugh
of those guys are way because all these
crazy people sad crazy people are
calling up for all we know our listeners
are like that though sorry yeah yeah I
don't think so I I don't feel like we
attract this type of said people that
don't have anybody talked it was like
let's call art Bell and talk about my
theory that I took an elevator to where
I love to our bill our bill was awesome
yeah yeah he could put on a show and
he'd have yet and he was always he
always know how to handle guests very
well yeah and you know he gives a guest
you know a chance to see ya even if it
was just something just totally
impossible art Bell would handle it the
right way he'll be like yeah I'm doing
re sometimes Jordan or II get kind of I
don't know asking a mystery guest
sometimes but you know please hung up on
him a couple of times yeah I think we
realized that he was just like click you
have you had a cold I have to hang up on
you yeah oh yeah I remember your accent
too strong yes I created by yeah I
remember that yeah that was that was
pretty rude okay so anyway so this lady
calls in to coast to coast in 2014 and
she said that she worked for NASA in
1979 and her job was downloading
telemetry data and she said that there
was a live feed for Mars in 1979 and
that she saw men walking on Mars yeah
but you can't prove this woman's
identity no that's what I mean I just
say the whole thing the whole thing's
ridiculous yeah
they could get to Mars at any earth
agency could get to Mars they would let
everybody know yeah they would even if
it was some kind of a CIA type
operations best me back in those days
because it would have been it would have
been something to rub in the face of the
Soviets during that time that was a Cold
War
you know they'd be like we're on Mars
and you're not in your family and one of
the things one of the things our space
program wanted to do I believe this is
in the 50s of the 60s is they wanted to
do a nuclear strike on the moon to show
the Soviet Union that we could put a
bomb on the moon yeah to see if they
could do it there's a good chance to
follow that ghe if you could yes
see if you can do that I mean that
that's what it was like back in the Cold
War so you know if they get a quick
swing in just dick swinging on a major
level yank it out on the massive scale
so like you said anything anything that
we discovered that was like kick ass
yeah we show it off they would have been
me in Italy all of it like we had a
secret space program to go to Mars they
would announce it the minute hit Mars
check it out Soviets from Mars and
you're not and we brought an atomic Bob
with us Thank You Bert atomic bomb we're
gonna take it to the top of a limpet mom
I said it up third a mega table see
biggest volcano in a soulless [ __ ] --is
ha ha yeah I know wait was a little kid
dude no time literally like that is that
oh man what like a very funny guy
thought men were men and testicles were
enormous
there you go okay so there was another
similar one too now this guy also said
that he worked for NASA or worked under
their auspices and he said that he
discovered organic life in the soil
samples in 1976 oh that was said it was
covered up
Gilbert Levin was his name he's talking
about the results that came back Matt
one Lander yeah well this is in the 70s
976 and they had soil samples and he had
found organic that's actually true but
now but there were two other samples
that they didn't find any right so
they're still they're still up in the
air yeah they're still like debating
about it what they're talking about
there is that one of those sort of
samples came back positive with the
tests that they had right time and
there's they now think that possibly was
a false positive right so that was it
could have been could have been or it
could have been organic like this does
not that's not great that's not crazy
either no it's still an unknown but that
particular conspiracy theory is not a
conspiracy yeah that's like I said that
do and it's like that's kind of like the
meteorite that fell on earth and it's
like you know hey or amazing yeah that's
not crazy that that could totally happen
I wouldn't be shocked now this one is a
little more crazy and since you were
talking about setting off a bomb on
Olympus Mons there are there is a
propulsion scientist who in 2014
thinks that because they're in the
atmosphere of Mars there's a lot of
large amount of xenon 129
and there's like a lot of uranium and
thorium in the soil so he thinks at some
stage that there had to have been at
least two nuclear explosions occurring
on the surface of Mars not plausible but
you know what meteorites can do that
that's what I mean
see because yeah it's like if he was
saying it was like it's some kind of
natural explosion Griffin yeah okay
that's not crazy however he's also said
that Cydonia has all the hallmarks of an
advanced humanoid so visited at which
point because right off the rails his
time becomes [ __ ] the tengu Scott
event was a meteor that came in and went
new and but yeah and what off about
having on any planet yes if you have a
thick enough atmosphere yes well no you
don't even need that soon as it hits the
surface you could if the masses and the
velocities are correct it could go yeah
that's yeah so that's that's not to say
like I said it's we're not saying that
nuclear explosions didn't happen on Mars
were saying that it wasn't people it
wasn't people are when the aliens it
wasn't weapons
all right it might have just happened
you know naturally cuz [ __ ] like that
does happen where's the kaboom that was
supposed to be an earth-shattering
kaboom
there were also
reports that a Stargate was found this
is our 2015 and this is like I said this
is UFO guys so of course they're always
you know they see like a picture of
something that's kind of half buried and
that's that's kind of it kind of looks
like a metal something or other so like
oh well it must be a Stargate meaning
you know I can get all these different
that's not knocking on UFO guys because
UFO guys are run the gambit from wacky
to plausible you know some of the UFO
guys I think a respectable that's what I
mean and that's why it because you know
what michio kaku is the MFO guy yeah you
can't discount all these some of these
some of these reports are oh yeah and
I'm gonna saying that I think I
mentioned I think we mentioned this on
the show we did about what was the UFO
show we do oh yeah over Illinois oh yeah
real that triangle one yeah I'm not
saying because I think it's very likely
that there is life elsewhere in the
universe that's very likely I think it
just it just has to be yeah I mean as
vast as everything is and all these
earth like I know that word that we're
coming up with now there's gotta be I
don't know how close it is I don't know
it's been here I think that's you know
that's another issue right but I
definitely do think it's out there
someplace
alright and if it's intelligent enough
if it's advanced enough you know could
they have come up with some technology
to come all the way here if it's sure I
don't think that's that crazy if it's
coming here it's far in advance of uh oh
yeah and I don't even think it'd be
biological anymore be having computers
with living robots of some sort yeah but
by allowed to being and biological
entity is kind of a disadvantage be a
lot better if you could download your
mind to your consciousness or your soul
into some kind of a robotic apparatus
well yeah because then you could go
anywhere I know any worry about mewed be
I want to genuine have to worry about
water you wouldn't have to worry about
the distances you would have to worry
about it you'd be immortal yeah more or
less
yeah I kind of feel like if they're if
they're advanced enough to a visited
here then yeah they're probably that's
not that's not that's not so far out
when you think about it if the mind is
some kind of quantum
process going on inside the brain could
you download your consciousness into a
computer and live in that that sounds
crazy in a way today but not really not
really I don't think that's that be
something that you might be able to do
within a hundred years yeah maybe less
the way it the way that it grows that's
what I mean the technology has just been
like exponentially advancing I mean
think about when you saw stuff from like
the 50s and 60s when they were doing
quote-unquote sci-fi movies in some ways
they were way off but then in some ways
we kind of surpassed that by quite a bit
I mean we have prosthetic arms and legs
imagine one day you have an entire
prosthetic body including a prosthetic
brain yeah basically and you just
transferred your soul into this damn
thing yeah I would be awesome I mean
wait I kind of hope it happens soon and
then you could enter into the internet
you don't yeah your soul could in a
weird way and you'd live forever and you
could transfer your consciousness from
one artificial body to the to the next
so you wouldn't be limited to one by it
you could like my brain you could be a
spaceship you could be a vehicle you
could be everything and then you can
have a humanoid your transformer you'd
be like a transformer
yeah mastabas that's a bummer because
it's my imagination you know I would
think that in alien beings that could
travel these distances that we're
talking about even if they're even if
they're just you know warping or going
through wormhole type situations that
were holding or jumping across space
they're probably biologically very
superior to us which means they're
probably not biological I mean I
wouldn't be if our getting ramble around
space or anything maybe you're born as a
biological entity they live out a
certain life certain amount of time then
when they started getting old and dying
they become a technological and identity
kind of like the way a butterfly you
know goes through a metamorphosis and
becomes you know or a worm go through
that morphs becomes a butterfly maybe
that's how they how their life cycle
might work their biological for a
certain period of time then when they
get old they turn into a robot yeah
weird you know look at that so I'm
talking I'm talking about yeah imagine
I'm just imagining the possibilities
yeah the advantages oh yeah but you know
edit that into account
you're talking about these Mars yeah
although in bribery but I you know it's
like obviously none of this stuff is
happening on Mars like I said if there
was life on Mars now or if there was at
some point the past I think that's
totally plausible but like you said it
was it was microbes microns it was coral
or something like that right no but it
still be there yeah maybe yeah but I
don't
it was always primitive life it probably
always still is I mean if you were
somehow tunneled through the surface of
Mars find an underground lake a huge
underground lake with basically a sea of
water in it and there was life in it
you'd be lucky to find fish in it I
think because you had to have a
lifecycle a hole yeah you have to have
what would he call it a habitat yeah and
you needle you mean a lot of stuff to
support large right complicated so I
can't I think it would probably just be
mic for micros probably I'd be lucky to
find something like because they're
pretty hearty like some types of them
are I mean some of them can travel
through space like on meteors and things
like that time extreme file yeah I don't
be a customer files get too big all
right so that's the thing so I think
that's all it would be so all these
people that are claiming that they see
these pictures oh there's a woman on
Mars oh there's Bigfoot on Mars so
there's a shoe on Mars their phones or
whatever so it's nothing it's rocks its
rocks its pieces of space junk
it's optical illusions there's nobody
there
there's nobody there and I know that's
kind of sad but that's not to say that
there's not there's somebody's in other
places just not Mars there's going to be
any kind of artifacts on Mars they've
got there because extraterrestrial put
them nuts in there yeah and I think and
why would they do that being able to do
that because that's the dumb thing to
it's people think that people put that
aliens put pyramids on earth and stuff
like that and that's [ __ ] too right
now when I say extraterrestrials put
them in there I'm talking about things
from outside the solar system or yeah
creatures that did not originate on Mars
maybe they stopped off and put something
there I think I think if any kind of
extraterrestrials or aliens placed
anything on Mars they placed it there
for the purpose and it was placed that
they're like a like a marker or a
monument to attract attention for future
creatures to see it which means that we
would easily spot it or they were just
trolling I think
you guys in like two billion years your
boy on I'm going to see this and they're
going to [ __ ] their pants bro it'll be
funny as hell just not there's any signs
of any kind of alien activity or ever on
Mars no it's just it's like I said it's
just rotted they are leaving if they
want to leave some on Mars for us they
wouldn't left it on Mars or left it on
the moon yeah because we can see that
better than rapped there's no there's no
evidence of anything ever landed on the
moon inside
besides human beings yeah it sucks that
that's true but like I said maybe
there's maybe there's a intelligent
alien somewhere else just on Mars that's
all admitted anything at any end this
off by one saying one thing I believe
that they will find exits for rest
riyals soon but it'll be two optical
stuff because they're starting to
actually being able to see some of these
yeah planets
what is spectroscopy they'll be able to
find habitable planets using that
technique and then eventually they'll
build telescopes figured up to they were
good enough because I don't necessarily
think they have to be all that big they
just have to have a right type of
telescope under the right circumstances
they'll be able to actually image some
of those planets and you might see
something like city lights yeah
campfires that one that's going to
change the game that would be awesome I
hope that happens in our lifetimes
because I'm David Icke it may yeah they
think it may some of the technology they
know where a lot of these planets are
they now have an image them and that's
only fifteen twenty years away in some
cases so that could be cool yep okay so
I hope you enjoyed the show and if you
like the show please subscribe to our
YouTube channel or download our the
audio version on Project Entertainment
Network also we have t-shirts tell if
you go to WWE my there's five different
t-shirts there that you can have and I
think that's probably about all that we
have to say at the end right we want to
make a Snake Plissken t-shirt
yeah those you guys are like this
necklace and I love this day from you
and I got this concept for a sneak
Plaskett t-shirt Jace's oh yeah I could
do that it'll have a cobra face like a
like a Cobra from a from a for Cobra
emblem yeah and its mouth assist whiskey
and with a mac-10 exerciser
and it's good to 7pi thought and maybe
say New York on the back of it yeah I'd
be awesome that would be a cool shirt
I'm gonna have to I'll get around to
making it yeah it'll just be it'll look
kind of military okay okay all right so
that'll do it for this episode of 13
o'clock be sure to tune in next Tuesday
[Music]
[Music]